ich habe schon mal ein video hochgeladen
in dem ich einen test gemacht habt ihr
mir bewiesen hat wer meine youtube
freundin sein soll nein nein nein ich
würde doch dann habe ich mir gedacht
meine damen und herren dafür bereits
herausgefunden haben welche youtube in
meine freundin sein sollte finden wir
heute einfach heraus welcher youtuber
mein freund wäre let's get the party
started wie begrüßt er seine fans ich
weiß es nicht weil ich ihn ja noch nicht
kenne und hallo meine lieben freunde das
ist unterschiedlich aloha freunde oder
hallöchen popöchen das hier ist
definitiv grandtour freunde ich habe
überhaupt keine ahnung ich würde einfach
mal sagen das ist unterschiedlich
also bei mir ist es ja so dass ich
eigentlich immer hallo mein name ist
luca sage allerdings zwischendurch auch
wir heute mal gar nichts sagen als
begrüßung frage nummer 2 welche
charaktereigenschaften sind dir wichtig
er soll sozial engagiert sein und gerne
seinen senf dazugeben das wie wie passt
das zusammen sozial engagiert das hört
sich noch richtig richtig richtig lieben
und netten person an und dann die seinen
senf dazugeben das hört sich nach von
besserwisser an er muss mich zum lachen
bringen können er muss humorvoller
soziale aus ja mein freund sollte
humorvoll asozial und liebevoll sein
oder sollte mein freund etwa mutig aber
auch einfühlsame und witzig sein
ich würde sagen humorvoll sozial und
liebevoll wende asozial stehen würde
würde ich das natürlich auch nehmen
welche haarfarbe gefällt dir am besten
braun mir egal ich mag alles blond oder
dunkelblond oder dunkelbraun bis schwarz
an der stelle muss ich leider sagen ich
bin nicht schwul von daher kann ich
jetzt nicht sagen was ich bei jungs nice
finde an also bezogen auf die haarfarbe
bei frauen will ich allerdings ganz klar
sagen blond und dann freut sich dass
jetzt auch hier einfach mal an
ja wenn er jetzt sonne meer ist ein bier
ankommen würde und die hat anstatt
blonde braune haare dann würde ich dann
natürlich aber auch nicht nein sagen als
nächstes geht es hier um die augenfarbe
und zwar für mich da ganz klar sagen
grün oder blau ich weiß nicht ich selber
grüne augen ich feiere es auch
eigentlich aber ich würde sagen bei
mädchen er blaue lauert fast jedes mädel
ich finde so
warum mädel es geht um jungs luca daher
würde ich sagen grün weil es glaube ich
die seltenste augenfarbe ist dies
irgendwie gilt also ich habe mich
eigentlich schon glücklich schätzen weil
jeder hat ja irgendwie blaue oder braune
was musst dein freund können er muss
sich für die welt interessieren und ein
ich interessiere mich auch für die welt
ich habe heute morgen noch einen kiosk
gekauft oder muss er etwa mut haben und
niemals ängstlich sein ein richtiger
mann eben
er muss gut mit worten umgehen können
oder er muss sich immer etwas neues
einfallen lassen
ich würde sagen dass gar nichts davon
mein frau das einzige wenn wenn ich im
weiblich wäre und was ich von einem
freund erwarten würde wäre dass er lieb
und lustig ist also dass man einerseits
merkt dass man gewertschätzt wird und
dass die person einen marken auf der
anderen seite dass er humor hat und dass
es nicht langweilig ist mit dem
abzuhängen
hier steht allerdings so ein schwachsinn
wie für die feld interessieren dann muss
ein standpunkt haben er muss darf
niemals ängstlich sein der muss gut mit
worten umgehen können er ist der autor
oder was ich muss sagen er muss sich
immer etwas neues einfallen lassen also
damit halt irgendwie abwechslung
auftaucht was ist dir in einer beziehung
wichtig kuscheln der spaß gespräch und
socken oder die momente der zweisamkeit
und ganz viel gefühl oh mein gott wer
hat das denn da hin geschrieben ich
würde sagen der spaß ist in einer
beziehung wichtig eigentlich ist es ja
die liebe die da wichtig ist aber naja
gut okay der kleidungsstil
da sind wir jetzt coole jeans cooles
shirt coole sneakers 1 und keri jeans
shirt lederjacke oder lässig ich mag
apps was ist wenn ich sagen würde
lässt sich aber ich mag keine caps ich
würde einfach sagen coole jeans t shirt
und coole sneakers dann fragen 08 bad
oder nicht war das ist die frage die
sich selbst keine habe
[Musik]
wie ist der sohn eurer beziehung das
werde ich dann sehen ja dass also ich
weiß ja noch nicht wie er in einer
beziehung mit mäßig weiß ja nicht mal
wer er ist wenn du selbst youtuber wer
ich bin ich bin youtube und in welchem
gebiet wäre ich dann youtuber locken
oder sowas in der art komme die
eigentlich gar nichts oder let's play
und das war gar nix also das heißt ich
hochladen kann man auch eigentlich in
keine schublade packen letzte frage von
diesem test meine damen und herren und
zwar wenn du eine beliebige reise machen
könnten welche wäre das
in die staaten nach tokio oder bangkok
einen road trip in die usa oder irgendwo
innerhalb deutschlands ich würde sagen
ein cooler job in den usa ganz ehrlich
tokio und bangkok reizt mich null komma
null starten war ich schon mal
deutschlands da wohnig und road trip in
die usa habe ich noch nie gemacht also
irgendwie westküste langen san francisco
runter nach adelaide dann vielleicht
eine nacht in vegas
[Musik]
whitey
das sind drei leute das heißt laut
diesem test führe ich dann eine vierer
beziehung ja cool allerdings meiner der
haben und herren ich habe natürlich
nicht nur einen test rausgesucht sondern
auch einen zweiten
hier ist die erste frage wie ist deine
art ich würde sagen lustig machen wir
direkt mal schnell weiter wie groß bist
du größer als 190 tatsächlich freunde
ich bin 193 also an alle also alle
zuschauer die ich bisher je getroffen
haben jeder hat irgendwie gefühl gesagt
viel größer als in meinen videos bin ich
so groß auf dem smartphone vielleicht
sogar nur so groß
natürlich bin ich größer welche
haarfarbe hast du blond habe ich welcher
content spricht dich am meisten an da
würde ich sagen lifestyle schaue ich am
liebsten welche augenfarbe habe ich grün
wie glaubt grün jetzt verwechsle ich
schon grau mit grün bis der andere leute
haben rot grün schwäche ich habe einen
grau grün schwäche ja lass mal daumen
hoch da freunde bei dem video
wenn ihr in der luke rusal figur habe
ich hier einfach mal normal und
trainiert angekreuzt also ich bin jetzt
193 groß ich wiege so 82 kilo ich glaube
das ist im durchschnitt wenn nicht sogar
ein bisschen unter dem durchschnitt die
alte bist du ich bin es gibt noch vier
verschiedene auswahlmöglichkeiten
dann bin ich natürlich 13 spiel zu ein
instrument im ja ich spiele ein wenig
klavier würde ich da mal ankreuzen
bist du oft auf youtube unterwegs war
oft aber nicht zu viele nein ich hatte
ja den ganzen tag ich würde sagen zwar
oft aber nicht zu viel und die letzte
frage freunde was spielst du später
erlernen hotelfachfrau dass ihr wollt
schon immer werden also bis vor kurzem
hätte ich gesagt ich bin noch am
studieren aber ich würde dann mal sagen
ich möchte selbstständig werden das
heißt freunde auswertung jetzt wird es
spannend
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
freunde spaß ich kenne dieses nicht aber
so 100 prozent passt zu ihnen kundschaft
an luca du bist verrückt und typisch
blondie wäre was für typisch blond alter
willst du mich verarschen ihr werde ein
absolutes dreamteam du bist hilfsbereit
und süß sowie luca danke dass du den
test gemacht hast dankeschön an den quiz
hersteller dass sich hilfsbereit und süß
bin
danke dass ich auch typisch blond bin
also freunde dass ich würde sagen mein
youtube freund ist entweder whitey dafür
ich eine vierer beziehung mit denen oder
ich selbst klingt ganz schön dazu haben
allerdings nicht mit sich selbst
zusammen sein kann und auch nicht zu
viert eine beziehung für außer man ist
echt ein verstörender mensch habe ich
hier noch ein alles entscheidendes
rausgesucht und zwar welcher frösche
youtuber wäre dein freund es geht also
nur im fresche leute was sind deine
hobbys musik und dumser das ja das kommt
eigentlich schon direkt hin apropos
musikfreunde einem ich hab so habe ich
noch nicht so richtig in einem youtube
video von mir angesprochen allerdings
habe ich soundcloud und lade dort
mixtapes hoch also wie ich remixes von
liedern zusammen mixa dass es ein großes
lied wird und ich habe mir überlegt dass
bald mal auf youtube zu machen weil ich
das jetzt seit einem jahr auch sound ort
mache und das hat auch millionen plays
die ganzen sachen und so aber auf
youtube keine ahnung was haltet ihr
davon wie ich ein bisschen auflege
bisschen musik bisschen kopfhörer auf
bis sie mixen lasst mir leid da wenn ich
das mal bald machen soll was willst du
denn gerne definitiv pizza gibt es
glaube ich überhaupt keine frage
gibt es dinge die du hast wenn der
computer abstürzt das ist mir soeben
passiert es gibt nichts was ich hasse
diese eine bestimmte frage wenn ich mir
den kleinen zeh oh mein gott
definitiv das spiel
willst du ein instrument haben wir hier
schon wieder ich würde sagen ja klar wir
würde ich an kreuz habe ich kann halt
nicht so richtig was ich würde einfach
sagen nein weil hier auch steht und ich
mag singen ich mag singen gar nicht
welches landmarken von diesen am
liebsten in china england belgien
österreich oder deutschland ich würde
sagen england
mic
und welcher gegenstand von denen passt
zu dir reist dach couch bentheimer
a
reis
also ich esse gern reist ihr solltet ihr
auswählen und zwar bekannt zur
erdmännchen rookie raupe drache aber ich
würde eigentlich und nehmen weil ich
liebe hunde über alles golden retriever
aber ich würde sagen erdmännchen weil
die sind lustig welche app gefällt dir
am besten instagram snap chat twitter
tumblr oder whatsapp tumblr auf keinen
fall nutze ich gar nicht so richtig
twitter letzter zeit auch nicht mehr so
viel habe ich fast eine million follower
aber bin ich eigentlich wirklich nicht
so aktiv auf instagram und snapshot bin
ich eigentlich schon so am aktivsten
nicht mal auf instagram den zweiten
dritten tag ein neues foto hoch aufs
nature täglich irgendwelche apsel folgt
mir hier laser luca heißt nicht auf
instagram und snapshot aber ich habe es
einfach mal instagram angekreuzt es war
ein hartes kopf an kopf mit snapshot
dann haben wir fragen immer neuen
haushalts gegenstand sofa einmal
drehstuhl kochlöffel lappen
warum sind das so viele smileys drei
wochen später also ich habe jetzt mal
überlegt und habe mir mal gedanken
darüber gemacht welche von den fünf
gegenständen hier meistens mit passen
würde deswegen will ich sagen lappen
das kommt eigentlich relativ gut hin
sowie für diese spezielle chris wir
hoffen es hat euch trotzdem gefallen so
der rookie liebt euch das einhorn auch
yahoo youtube videos oder anliegen
ich würde einfach sagen tschüss
wir wollen jetzt wissen welcher frösche
youtuber zu mir passt zum ersten mal
sagst du in einem supermarkt ihr wart
beide auf der suche nach reis so kam die
ins gespräch und haben rezepte befinden
nummern ausgetauscht bald stellte sich
heraus dass ihm eigentlich gar nicht
richtig kochen kommt so kam es dass du
fast jeden tag haben sowie zum kochen
hat gegenleistung schenkte er die einen
antrag und fünf kinder
jo jo schonn kim region kommt ich weiß
nicht genau wie der name ausgesprochen
wird aber dass mein youtube freund nice
ist auch dass die kinder die wir
bekommen werden
julien felix bianca und unter anderem
auch luca heißen
also ich selbst bin mit schon kim
zusammen und habe mich selbst als kind
ist das nicht wahnsinn
an der stelle wird das heutige video ist
allerdings auch beenden meine damen und
herren wenn euch solche texte die ich
kurz ausgefallen beziehungsweise tests
ist der test du dich und ich küsse dich
anlass bei einen daumen hoch da freunde
und bei 50.000 leichtes ist eine riesige
summe ich weiß 50.000 menschen sind fünf
mal 10.000 menschen allerdings wenn ihr
diese summe unlike schafft freunde da
kommt demnächst ein neues quiz von
testen ihr könnt mir ja vielleicht
einfach mal quiz in die kommentare
schreiben also einfach den link einfügen
von test oder einfach den namen oder so
und dann schaue ich mir das mal anlass
vielleicht hoch und jetzt